the next game against finland
i played against him recently
and somehow i do
n't have any good memories of it in the core, funny i
can't
remember you exactly but he told me about that
funny so now i think we'll get
some modern defensive stuff again
yes i always play with c3
yes and now this funny variant where
i don't know exactly what to do about it i
'm the one so in all games
i have now always developed myself
goes back well well thought
jumper here five maybe well well
but
first of all  normal development make moves
as long as it always moves with his players that's
fine with me if knight c5
probably wants to play then
maybe get a bishop
maybe
a knight g5 could be the idea i
'll take that thing away as a precaution
then i can open it  standards for five
still had the full choice as here
in more games so now we
basically only have the royal children with the
bishop on c2
that is a bit controversial whether
it is good or not
ready in the abi four in front of
the advantage of the lovers of  2 is
definitely that he somehow helps to
stand up to him five so like here
now he just tries to prepare it with
violence but I'm
quite into z2 in there
the question is now how
exactly do we want to react when he
turns whom  typically comes
with the take and then somehow f4 in
addition I would have to pull the jumper
away, however, the
111 he jumps five gb 4 will only be
my good position
I could also
stay fulfilled and understand and say what do
you actually want there
is probably both quite good
with the next one I really like
it doesn’t bother me I’ll do
84 and watched myself progress on the queenside
so the super line-up can
somehow not be the case for the
attack
so there’s the question
can you now appear quite aggressive in some way
because  everything is so funny,
e.g. with the c55
the cbc springer
runner i3
is really stupid it certainly doesn’t matter
a little bit faster I have to get
here
somewhere it will be easy and makes
things here
so the question is now says c6
interesting in a special position yes that’s
why it’s interesting  because
he now temporarily brings the bishop to
the crappy square b 7 and I
now get the bishop here to c6,
well, he's doing
his thing, but
I'm not here now, so
I'm going too fast and too far  I have to say
that I almost always do magic in this
position because at some point I continue to
play stupidly but normally it wo
n't work anymore anyway
without the bishop well
as usual it's somehow
still dangerous probably
he would probably be after a7 or
where do I want to
stand for you for it  i'm still
important
so
in the tournee game the position is
now simply won refer
but
i've only seen 1 minute more
won because because nothing
works here basically basically has death
here now
can only research around  In the
best case, so to speak, but it's still
a bit uncomfortable, practically,
still nothing, I think
the h4 runner is useful as a blocking
stone, so I can do it again
if we can't think of anything else,
take a club in that subject,
I'm actually like that  much faster on
the line part has to go to the g1
well I would have to be extremely
stupid now there is also the threat of runner
g5 nothing helped her
very directly
because not changed funny well
yes there with two should
just cover everything here a little bit
the so the c4 eg so would like to do to
play six
and yes very much also adored
yes the miserable the miserable time yes yes
the coking plants
I can not believe it I have
not had a bandage yet
unbelievably really
there dam is remi present I would have
always lost for time yes all in all
a bad joke yes but
i still have three seconds do
not have to manage where they actually
manage not to grasp he
threatens nothing really
nothing
yes what can you do